redefinir el dispositivo militar en mali
esa es la idea que está ganando terreno
en parís
este compromiso internacional se produce
ahora en un nuevo contexto de exxon hubo
medidas para obstruir la junta ilegítima
de malí medidas para obstaculizar la
acción de la comunidad internacional y
de los estados europeos
ante la huida hacia adelante de la junta
que se acentúa cada vez más apoyamos la
reacción de los países de la cedeao que
la han condenado con firmeza y valentía
como el guarismo cutáneo el jefe de la
diplomacia francesa reaccionó a la
salida forzada del continente danés un
centenar de hombres miembros de la
fuerza especial europea tacuba al que se
le ha pedido abandonar el territorio
maliense según parís una decisión
irresponsable su homólogo maliense
respondió a estos comentarios en la
entrevista con france 24 horas son de
poco amparo en comentarios despectivos
que condenó y que son inaceptables y
creo que los insultos no son una prueba
de grandeza estamos dispuestos a
discutir con francia sobre cuestiones de
fondo en primer lugar no se trata de
medidas irresponsables lo que
pretendemos hacer es defender los
intereses de nuestro país desde antes de
uno de los países que contribuyen de
actuar deben de adoptar ahora una
estrategia común para intentar compensar
la salida de los soldados daneses
francia teme que las autoridades pongan
en peligro los futuros despliegues
previstos este año por noruega hungría
portugal rumanía y lituania